- [Narrator] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Wells Fargo.
Established 1852, re-established 2018.
(jaunty music)
This is Myron.
- Hi.
- [Narrator] Myron is an athlete.
- I played a little football in college.
- [Narrator] And ...
- I was a Rhodes Scholar.
- I played for the NFL.
- [Narrator] And ...
- I have a Master's degree
in Medical Anthropology.
- [Narrator] And ...
- And, I'm a neurosurgeon.
- [Narrator] Sheesh.
- My first dream
was to play professional football.
There's no question.
I was very active as a
young man, and I knew
that I was pretty good at it.
When I got to the fifth
grade, that's when I knew
I wanted to pursue my second dream.
I read a book called
Gifted Hands by Ben Carson,
who looked like me-he was black-
who came from a similar
socioeconomic background as me.
We didn't have much money
when we left the Bahamas
and came to America, and
the more I read about it
the more I knew that once I
was done playing football,
neurosurgery was gonna be the pathway
and the second chapter of my life.
I was the number one-rated
high school player
in the country for
football-recruited by everyone-
83 scholarship offers.
I always felt that football fed academics,
academics fed football.
- [Narrator] Myron spent his college years
playing football and shadowing doctors.
He graduated in two and a half years
and was expected to be a first
or second round draft pick
in the NFL with a
multi-million dollar contract,
but he also had a chance to study
at Oxford as a Rhodes scholar.
- I ended up deciding to go to Oxford
and saying no to the NFL.
I spent a year and a half over there.
I came back to the United States,
went into the draft and got
drafted in the sixth round
instead of the second or first,
made $70,000 instead of six million.
Played for three years, got out healthy,
felt good about my time there,
and, frankly, made enough money
to pay for medical school.
I didn't have any lasting concussions,
and my hands were okay to where I was able
to do surgery in the operating room;
and so I left on my own volition.
Started medical school, and here I am now.
- [Narrator] Since head
injuries are common
on the football field,
Myron works to impress
the importance of avoiding
concussions on young players.
But for Myron, his days of
tackling are behind him.
- Football was great for
that season of my life,
but now this is it.
This is the pinnacle.
This is where I belong,
and I've told my parents
several times over and over again.
They ask me, "Myron, how do you feel
"what you're doin' now?
"How do you feel?"
I said, "Mommy and Daddy, I feel like this
"is where I belong."
- [Patient] So, did you say
you played a sport before?
- [Myron] Yes, I played football.
(soft ambient music)